enos presents Volvo v40 hatchback she
says it's like a premium version of the
VW Golf eNOS is going to find out
whether the v4 T's design and
top-of-the-line features will set it
apart from its compact competitors the
v40 sleek design is distinctive that
includes the v-shaped hood which gives
the car a look that's at once bold and
elegant the rear of the car features a
streamlined combination of glass and
metal that surrounds the six side and
tailgate other attractive features
include the angular taillights that rise
to the C pillar
untie them what penis points out that
the v40 is powered by the all-new
driving powertrain which includes the
2-liter engine there's a whole range of
units to choose from diesel and gasoline
and various performance options freshen
and let some stupid anger Borden vadym
come
there are three diesel and three
gasoline engine options we're testing
the middle diesel model which comes with
a manual 6-speed gearbox all models
though are also available with automatic
transmission the short throw shifter has
a sports car feel to it and the
suspension is comfortably tuned
the v40 goes from 0 to 100 km/h in 8.4
seconds and has a top speed of 210 the
German price for the car we're testing
today is just under 30 thousand euros
add on a few accessories and it'll cost
a few grand more
deny my penis highlights Volvo's use of
fuel-efficient engines the d3 model that
we're testing generates 110 kilowatts
and uses just 3.8 liters of fuel to
cover 100 kilometers those numbers show
up on the dyno meter but with a torque
rating of 320 Newton meters it's so much
fun to accelerate quickly that people
will have a tough time hitting 3.8
liters
the v40 s interior looks very
Scandinavian it's functional but with
the occasional touch of extravagance
like the floating center console
among the optional extras is a leather
driver's seat complete with a seat
adjustment memory function ena says the
v40 has three main equipment options
today we're using the second one it's
got a great mix of colors materials and
surfaces she also likes the simple
design of the buttons it's all very well
designed and easy to operate the v40 s
back bench has plenty of room there are
some smart looking cupholders and you
can take out the central armrest so
you'll have even more space to stretch
out
the rear seats are split and can be
folded down to create plenty of cargo
space and when you fold them back up
you'll find hooks that you can hang your
shopping bags on
that penis really likes the design of
the Volvo v40 and really enjoyed driving
it in Germany the basic model costs
under 24 thousand euros what's more you
can have a large number of extra safety
features it comes standard equipped with
the city safety assistant and an
external airbag that stretches across
the front of the car to protect
pedestrians farmers but even so cyber
authorizers Volvo has a solid reputation
for building safe cars in the v40
continues that tradition we think the
improvements that Volvo has made to this
model will help put it out front of the
competition and sets a new standard for
pedestrian protection